[speaking foreign language]
WOMAN: I seek refuge in you from
the difficulties of affliction
and the burdens of hardship,
from evil judgments,
and from my enemies
maliciously rejoicing.
He's begging Allah
to protect him.
Hey, man, did
you see the news?
They just let that asshole go.
[yelling]
- Get out of here.
Get.
- Leave him alone.
He didn't do anything.
You shot that man?
[screaming]
I need a gun to protect the
kids when you're not around.
You'd be dangerous to
yourself and to the kids
more than anybody else.
Every year, Prince visits the
place where his wife and kids
were massacred by the
Serbs on the anniversary
of their deaths.
If you guys want a shot at
the guy behind Rip's murder,
the Prince is it.
Last time I heard the
words credible source
coming from you, things
did not turn out well.
They're exiting
through the back door.
Potential HVI just split
off with a bodyguard.
I recommend you execute.
It's not him.
[speaking foreign language]